welcome to the joint operational
media briefing at 10 am i welcome to the
podium miami-dade county mayor
daniela levine
i'm sorry i didn't scroll down my
apologies
lieutenant governor janet jeanette nunes
good morning as of 8 a.m this morning
the national hurricane center advisory
has also located 55 miles west of key
west moving north northwest at 12 miles
per hour
maximum winds are near 60 miles per hour
but elsa is expected
to near hurricane strength tonight prior
to making landfall in florida
we also expect also we'll be making
landfall along the florida west coast
tomorrow morning
it's important that floridians don't
focus necessarily on the cone as we know
impacts are expected well outside of the
area of the cone
the storm will likely be lopsided with
most of the rainfall to the east
of the center of the storm right now we
have
tropical storm warnings for 22 counties
along florida's west coast
and a hurricane watch is now in effect
for the florida coast stretching from
pinellas to dixie
storm surge also continues to be a
concern there is a storm surge
warning in effect for 12 counties
between taylor and lee counties on the
gulf coast
as we know near florida storm surge can
be dangerous and life-threatening we ask
that locals heed
the emergency warnings and do not go to
the beach much of north and central
florida
have experienced above normal rainfall
over the past two weeks
so we're anticipating an increase in
potential flash flooding conditions
especially since we've seen that 300
percent increase in the last 14 days
ahead of the storm the state has issued
a state of emergency to allow for
flexibility of response and resources
we have received and requested an
emergency declaration from fema
we have more than 8 000 electrical
workers on standby
the governor continues to be in constant
communications with the
counties that are likely to be impacted
to make sure that they have sufficient
resources they've been putting in their
requests and we've been filling them
expeditiously as
needed we will continue to monitor that
situation
as well as the governor continues to
remain focused on the efforts here on
surfside
we ask floridians to please begin their
preparations
that includes being prepared to
potentially be without power for a few
days
have enough food have enough water for
each person in your family including
pets
please stay tuned to florida's weather
channel make sure that you are
constantly monitoring
all local official warnings if your area
is asked to be evacuated
it is for your own safety counties will
open shelters as
as needed especially for special needs
if they issue evacuations
please be careful as you begin to make
your storm preparations
the governor and our division of
emergency management director have been
have consistently reminded floridians
the dangers of generators
make sure you use proper tools proper
materials if you're cutting down trees
make sure you do that safely
overall the state and floridians we know
are well equipped to be able to handle
this storm
we have our state emergency response
teams working round the clock
to ensure counties have all the
resources they need
and i'll say a few words in spanish
apart
from
is
[Music]
a
a
thank you very much lieutenant governor
miami-dade county mayor daniela lavinka
good morning everyone here we are on the
morning
of day 13.
active search and rescue continued
throughout the night
and these teams continue through
extremely adverse and challenging
conditions through the rain and through
the wind they have continued searching
they paused only briefly for lightning
which is legally required for up to 30
minutes
for pauses whenever there's a lightning
strike within two and a half miles
of the site regarding the impacts of
tropical storm elsa
we do continue to expect occasional
gusts and strong showers today
and we're closely monitoring the weather
and we now have our weather service
embedded within our search and rescue
teams
to work closely to track for any changes
that could impact the work
to assure the safety of our first
responders
through the team's ongoing efforts we
have recovered
four additional victims the number of
confirmed deaths
is now 32 with
26 of those identified 191 people are
accounted for
and we have 113 reports
of people who are potentially
unaccounted for
as i've mentioned before these the
detectives are conducting
ongoing and very thorough review
of these these names and these reports
many were originally submitted
incomplete so if they we may only have a
name
without an apartment number without a
date of birth
or other details so of that 113
only around 70 of those are people we
have been able to confirm
were in fact in the building during the
collapse
our detectives continue to follow up on
every single report
that was submitted but in many of these
cases they aren't able to reach
the person who originally submitted the
report so it's a distant relative
or someone overseas without clear
details and that
that makes it very difficult for us to
determine whether an individual was
in fact in the building we continue to
urge
all of the families who are missing
loved ones to please
reach out and connect with us so that
our detectives
can file missing persons reports with
the police and
we want to confirm every single account
every single life that has been lost is
a beloved family friend
a best someone's child or parent or
niece or cousin or grandparent and we
know that waiting for news is
unbearable the waiting the waiting and
the waiting
is unbearable and so
receiving that your loved one is gone is
also
unbearable but we need information to be
able to
confirm exactly who is missing
please continue to hold all of the
families in your hands and your hearts
and in your prayers during this
unimaginably difficult time
we're also working hard to provide
respite and support to the men and women
of the usar teams wherever possible and
today
we brought in cooling stations closer to
the site to provide relief from the
ongoing heat
as well as county buses where they can
take quick breaks from the wind and
other conditions
we're also grateful to the support from
royal caribbean
which is providing a doc ship where
first responders can also rest
between the ships nist our federal
partner continues to work closely with
structural specialists with detectives
and the fire rescue crews
on site as the evidence gathering
process
is well underway the teams are extremely
well coordinated they're capturing all
possible
insights from the debris and all
evidence is being properly
tagged and logged the us geological
survey
and national science foundation are also
sending additional staff
and the lidar scanners are working so
that we can better analyze
the debris given the rough terrain of
the pile
and to make sure that we have the proper
equipment and personnel
on the site all this evidence will be
critical to the nist eventual
fact-finding report
and as we are working on all levels
local state and federal to provide
answers
and accountability for the victims of
this unthinkable tragedy
and we're going to be making policy
changes as you know at every level
and at every step in the building
process to ensure
that this can never ever happen
again
[Music]
a
[Music]
gracias gracias
thank you madam mayor serbsite mayor
charles burkett
good morning this morning i was up with
the family
and uh learned that overnight
uh the work did briefly stop regarding
lightning
but has returned to full power it did
return to full power shortly afterwards
the wind is hampering the large cranes
moving very heavy debris
that's a challenge that they're
attempting to work around right now
i met with the families this morning
with some families
and the losses to them are catastrophic
one family i met with had a daughter
who had recently graduated
law school recently married in
january and obviously the family is
distraught
and wanting to know um you know every
detail about what's happening
and whether or not their daughter and
their son-in-law are going to be found i
told them
that we are working 24 hours a day
seven days a week non-stop with waves of
search and rescue teams
and that the miami-dade rescue teams out
there
including the police and our foreign
friends who are also assisting are doing
everything they possibly can
and they are as intent on pulling
everybody out of that debris pile
as the families are in having those
family members
pulled out governor desantis
i met with yesterday thank you
lieutenant for coming today
um and governor desantis wants to
supplement the charitable efforts that
are ongoing now
and has asked me to work on that project
his concern is that nobody falls through
the cracks with respect to funding
so there are significant donors that i
will be working with and we will be
working to
supplement all of the funds that are
available to the families
and make sure that everybody gets what
they need
i know mayor cava was at the
meeting this morning also meeting with
families consoling them
providing their information and letting
them know they have our 100 percent
support thank you mayor cava for doing
that
as usual the town of surfside and i
stand ready to provide
any support to the rescue effect rescue
effort rather that we can
we're small but we're here we're on the
ground
our staff is working 12 to 18 hours a
day and we will continue to do whatever
we can to
support the effort we are currently
responding to
inquiries uh from our large buildings in
town regarding the collapse
and advising them that they should do
a full structural review of their
systems
uh in addition we are doing a deep dive
with respect to the sister building you
know
called uh champlain north which is
essentially
the same building built by the same
developer at the same time
with the same plans probably with the
same materials
and given we do not know why the first
building fell down
we have significant concerns about that
building and the residents in there you
know from the very beginning
we work to make sure that those
residents had alternative housing if
they wanted it
uh several of them have taken us up on
that offer
uh but right now we continue to work
with the condominium board
to make sure that uh well we can't make
sure but we're going to do everything we
can
to look at those structural systems
including ground penetrating radar
the columns the beams the slabs and try
to get our arms around
what may be happening what did happen
and uh
but like i said we have some concerns
about not just some but
deep concerns about that building
especially given we don't know
uh what has happened there but our
engineer
is actively working on it as our town
official is
lastly i want to uh relay
and again i'm going to do this publicly
and i know mayor cava has been
extremely compassionate and supportive
of the families they've asked me
if they can somehow get back down to the
site to visit
i told them that i support that idea of
course we have to work around
the rescue efforts and whether we do it
over the course of a couple days
i think it would be very very good for
those families to again
see the amazing efforts that are being
expended on
their behalf and i will work with
mayor cava to see if we can make that
happen for the families thank you very
much
thank you mr mayor served side vice
mayor tina paul
thank you good morning buenos dias
in my first time addressing everyone as
a whole i just want to say that we are
all
in in this together the word the word
that comes to mind first is gratitude
gratitude for all the officials standing
behind me here standing with our
community for you
the media standing with our community
we've all been here together since day
one
whether you see me here or you see me on
the field i'm there for the people these
are my people this is my community this
is our community
and i just want to express gratitude for
everyone
who is helping in this collaborative
effort and especially my town staff who
have worked hard
tirelessly behind the scenes the
volunteers
the members of our community i also want
to ask
to keep in mind this is about our
humanity this is about the soul of our
community about the soul of the town of
serve side and the soul of the lost
people that are still unaccounted for
and
please keep that in mind that's what
we're praying for that's what we're
working for
we have an amazing community and our
full support
from around the world is amazing it's
keeping us going
it's keeping us strong it's keeping us
whole we're broken right now but we will
we will be whole again thank you so much
for being here with us
thank you madam vice mayor miami-dade
fire rescue chief alan kaminski
good morning uh we're continuous our
search efforts all throughout the entire
debris cloud all throughout the night
as mentioned we did have one stop period
approximately at 1am
due to the incoming weather
thunderstorms and the ones coming
through
but we were implementing our search
again and again emphasizing searching
uh the entire all grids
currently last operational period i'll
still have our federal resources here on
site
so our virginia team pennsylvania ohio
indiana and new jersey
as well as florida task force one and
florida task force two
working around the clock are we able to
remove 124 tons of debris which is
equivalent now to
5 million pounds of debris off the top
thank you chief miami-dade fire rescue
director of media public relations erica
benitez
buenos dias
is thank you erica and i welcome to the
podium our creole translator
leona letterboard
[Music]
as we go into our questions and answer
sessions we have deputy incident
commander charles surreal available
and the miami-dade police department
director freddie ramirez once again
raise your hand wait here called upon
and address the speaker police
spanish
hey um
uh i think every moment we have over 200
firefighters that are actively searching
on the pile
uh in regards to yes the grids that we
weren't able to
access with with the building uh that
was still remaining in place
uh we have been searching those areas b1
and d1 was those primary grids and then
partial into
b2 and d2 uh no unfortunately we haven't
you know come across and
let's get impressed uh this is all for
chief convincing
there was a report that you're having
issues with water in the parking garage
is that correct and where did the water
come from was it from the rain or from
fighting the fire earlier
multiple multiple sources uh yes early
on
when we first arrived the garage was
partially filled with water so uh
we were actually pumping throughout you
know once we maintained and were able to
suppress the uh
you know different water supply systems
uh also with the rain and also with then
when we were
you know attacking the fire throughout
so multiple times we've had to
uh pump out the lower garage
yeah this is regarding the ongoing
investigation uh i know it's a bit of a
broad question but
how much closer are we defining the
cause of this collapse
than we were 13 days ago
so as you all know we were focused
squarely
on search and rescue but while
preserving all
possible evidence and nist the national
institute for standards and technology
is leading the federal investigation and
they have been able to tag
all of the evidence that has been
already gathered and they
are embedded and working with our police
department
to tag everything that is coming through
the pile
they've also conducted ligar about 3d
picture taking up the building before
the demolition
and of course they've been speaking as
well to many many people with
information
that could contribute to understanding
the causes so
through nisk we'll be having periodic
updates obviously many many other people
are seeking information our state
attorney is coordinating locally what
would
the future the future investigation so
it's it's very
early to name any uh
sources but of course everything is
under review
they can repeat the same thing
what evidence are you seeing that makes
you so hopeful of finding people alive
well we're definitely searching i mean
you know unfortunately we're not seeing
anything positive uh that continues
in that sense you know the key things
we're looking for all throughout in
regards to voice space livable spaces
you know we're not coming across that so
we're you know actively searching as
aggressive as we can
uh you know to see if we can assist with
the families and locate individuals
and we don't know yet i mean i don't you
know we're actively looking into it and
having different dialogues in regards to
our strategies
we've got christian here followed by my
no we haven't been able to clear any of
the search grids uh
again uh g1 and you know g2 g3 in the
garage areas
you know hopefully we can we can get to
sooner in regards to those aspects
uh the other grids is where the entire
structures fell
into uh and yes i mean definitely uh
with this type of collapse and that
pancake
you know there are several layers of
floors per se
um you know that would be subterrane but
the three that
had significant flooding through the
water yes we we've actively
you know maintained pump and water
anytime their needs and yes that's just
being fit
over here followed by a lady
um
i don't have the exact uh
feet per se to let you know um
definitely floor wise we
you know we've definitely de-layered
several several floors
um but each grid is different you know
just again the magnitude of this
collapse
and in the way the building collapsed in
certain uh
areas you know we've been able to go a
few floors lower and one grid per se
than the other i don't have the exact
number
um but you know we definitely haven't
been able to get to the
you know the lower floors per second
from victims that we rescued or yeah we
wouldn't be able to find it
last two questions right here sir
um sorry i thought
there been any injuries or have any of
the rescue personnel needed medical
treatment for any reason
after working on this retail we've been
very fortunate where we haven't had any
significant injuries to any of our
personnel or firefighters
we've had some minor dehydration
concerns uh you know obviously we're
working around the clock
uh you know these brave men and women
you know we're going
full speed 110 uh so it's uh
you know definitely a lot of work
extension that we're we're performing
so we've had a few dehydration as we
mentioned earlier with some
buses that we brought in to kind of help
with the rehab cycle
just to cool body temperature and stuff
but very fortunate no injuries
significant injuries
mayor opposition is going to be
extraordinary mountains
extraordinary amount of civil suits
being filed down the road
the condo board the conversations with
these people obviously you're dealing
with legal reps
obviously they have a sense of remorse
but how those conversations
gone even if you've had time to deal
with that
the whole world wants to know what
happened here and
especially those who are the victims
the survivors the family members of
those who are
in the pile clearly everybody wants to
know what happened so
we do have lawsuits that have been filed
we have numerous investigations
and um you know i look forward to
learning the truth as do we all but i
think it will be a while till everything
is is understood and i'm very confident
that especially the federal
investigative team
will get to the bottom of this and that
will learn
what what happened what could have been
prevented and how to make sure it never
happens again
thank you man we were able to squeeze
into last question we're gonna go with
nbc and finish off with telemundo
better explain the discrepancy number in
the 70 number
what is being done by those 43
individuals my
other follow-up was uh we could have
generally honored
suggesting that they should go into the
recovery process and i'm no expert on
this matter but there's been
our families who are also very eager to
recruit their bodies for burial purposes
if you guys were to go for the recovery
route could this process
your first question was about the
numbers
so as we've said all along we've taken
every single tip
into consideration people call
anonymously
people call and don't leave return phone
numbers
people call with partial information not
enough to really
secure whether that person may or may
not have been in the building
so we have been extremely diligent
in following through on all of those
leads
we know that there may be people in the
building that were in the building that
nobody has
called to identify so we want to be as
thorough as possible with that to be
said
we are now preparing to differentiate
between those that we could confirm
were in the building and those for whom
it's still
not confirmed in the way that we would
feel confident so we will be
continuing to update those numbers and
we'll bring you updates as soon as we
have them
as part of your team like trying to
reach out and follow those things oh yes
so
we have detectives constantly calling
they've reviewed
dozens of databases to to confirm
whether these people could have been
here so this is a very very thorough and
exhaustive process
obviously when your loved ones are
involved we will spare nothing
to make sure that we've correctly
identified
who was and who was not in that building
as far as whether moving into the next
phase
will speed up the process the answer is
we will continue as now to thoroughly
carefully uh sift through these piles
really you will not see a difference uh
we
we will be as thorough as we've been
throughout to carefully search for
bodies and belongings and to catalog
and to respectfully deal with
any remains that we want
how close are we to moving to the
recovery phase
of coverage
i want to say that for the family
members who
are waiting and waiting excruciatingly
waiting
for information they they know
what is happening they understand that
the news of their loved ones
may be tragic loss and
they uh as they're contacted
to let them know that a loved one has
passed
they're prepared for it and so i think
everybody will be ready when it's time
to move to the next phase
thank you folks our next joint
operational briefing will be at 5 30
this afternoon
same location thank you very much